hey what's up guys I'm Kay PhD here so
last week a Seuss promised that they
would be rolling out Android 4.1 jelly
bean to the transformer pad infinity
then they had delay they said all right
next week we'll roll it out
well here we are and on Monday morning
little did we know that that meant that
today we would be getting the
Transformer Pad Infinity jelly bean so
now the Transformer Pad Infinity the
transformer prime and the transformer
pad 300 all have Android 4.1 rolling on
them and this is what we're gonna be
taking a look at today Android on a
10-inch form-factor tablet and a little
bit of how it compares to Android 4.1 on
7-inch tablets so without any further
ado let's hop into this quick video and
take a look so this is what its gonna
first look like when you first get
Android 4.1 jelly bean installed on your
Transformer Pad Infinity now when we
first got Ice Cream Sandwich we were
introduced to that camera shortcut over
on the left and we get this nice
interesting effect here with our finger
but now we get the camera shortcut
beyond lock and Google now at the top
which I'll get to in a second but will
unlock here of course I have to swipe to
the right to unlock and use notice that
you get the same tablet UI that you get
with Android 4.0 so any 10-inch or I
guess anything greater than the size of
the Nexus 7 which is a unique seven inch
form factor you still get this tablet UI
so you don't get the swipe down
notification bar instead you get the
regular horizontal layout and you get a
regular notification down at the bottom
right hand corner so on the Nexus 7 you
didn't have these paginating icons at
the top but this is an asus thing so you
get to know what page you're on
and of course swiping from page to page
is really fast really really smooth
thanks to project butter and Android 4.1
so to see exactly what version of
Android you have you can go to settings
here and hit about tablet and you'll see
it's Android 4.1.1 jelly bean and of
course you get that little Easter Egg
here we can toss around multiple jelly
beans here but that's a good way to know
what version of the OS you have but
basically Google now is one of the
biggest new features and you have more
than one way to access it now if you go
to the app drawer which is again very
smooth you can open the google app now
and instead of just going to a search it
will actually bring you into the Google
Mail layout which has two columns of
cards which is actually pretty cool so
you have it's not really sorted
anyway but you might have multiple
calendar events over here and some more
sports cards over here so it's pretty
nice that you have more than one column
using all the resolution of this 1080p
displays real estate so I'll go ahead
and ask it you can also update or access
it by tapping this microphone over here
how cold is it in Alaska so you can see
that it's pretty responsive of course
just as fast as you'd expect it to be
Google now is very very fast and of
course you get the web search results
below if you ever need to question that
source of course it's very cold there
what is 25 + 25 all right well sometimes
it'll respond just by saying Google
other times it won't but that's one of
the unique features of Android 4.1 is
Google now and of course you still have
that a neat app tray like we said the
cards you I kind of preserves itself
here and you also get the new
backgrounds behind the widgets which
give you an outline of how big they look
so they all kind of have this uniform
look when you scroll through the widgets
and then the app drawer is of course
very smooth so that's Android 4.1 on the
Asus Transformer Pad Infinity
performance is extremely fast it is all
improved now because you know project
butter is just that awesome pretty much
brings the stability we've wanted with
Android 4.1 and it's it's just here to
stay now this is what Android was meant
to be and it's really really close to
stock here there's very few Asus
customizations the one asu's thing that
I think is really ugly is the
notification bar that's not from a sous
so if I go down here and use Asus
settings I don't know I happen to think
that looks really ugly so I definitely
don't enable that I uncheck that and you
get the nice expandable notifications at
Android 4.1 you can swipe them away and
of course clear all so that's it that's
Android 4.1 jelly bean hope you enjoyed
this quick look at it and tell me what
you think let me know if you're enjoying
it on your DP tablet
peace out guys
you